well I'm very pleased to be part
of this assembly and where confidence
you know this Monday after I finish my
seminar one of my students I think his
name is Travis approached me and said
professor I want to to ask you something
and so what well you know I am
graduating from college this academic
year I already have a nice job at least
for two years at the goldman sachs but
you know what my thing is really a
public service so I want your advice
professor if my aspiration is to be you
know to serve should I go after I do my
work at Goldman Sachs for two years
should I go to graduate school that was
his question and well I said well that's
a very tough question you know it's very
personal of course inside me I was
thinking why is he asking me this
and I thought first rather cynically
well maybe he's asking me because today
nowadays at least some politicians do
make a big effort to represent and set
themselves as educated or even ignorant
so maybe my student is asking me you
know whether if he is interested in
being in public service a politician
going for graduate school will not be
too much and he knows that I have a PhD
from this University and I happened to
be at some part of my life you know a
public servant politician and they say
in my country that a very successful one
so maybe that's why he is asking me
about that and in a few seconds he
really made me
about you know how serious his question
was and made me go back to my own
experience how I came here
and what happened after I came here and
and that also told me a lot about this
place the first time I came to New Haven
I came by bus from Boston in a ray
Humber bus stay at the Duncan hotel
where there were thousands of coaches in
my room by the way
but it was only twelve dollars and I
came here because I had been told to
come and talk to some professors this
was a few months before applying for
admission and I was introduced to a few
professors and in particular ones say
well I can see that you are under
prepare to come here your previous
studies maybe are not enough but I also
see that there may be some aspects that
will give you some opportunity to be
admitted so you should apply here and he
said and maybe you will be accepted to
other universities so I wanted to make a
promise you are admitted to those other
places but if you are admitted here
promise me your word that you will come
here and I said okay of course I was
right I was very lucky to be admitted
here and to a few other places and of
course I had committed to come here and
I came here the first thing that I
really found out is that he was
absolutely right I was terribly
underprepared to come here and I don't
know how I made it through the first
semester I think Rick lorina still
teases me about my grades in the first
semester
so but we prepare I was about anyways I
saw by the first semester and maybe did
a little bit well afterwards and
eventually got my my PhD here but the
reason why I got the PhD is because I
finished my dissertation but it was also
an adventure I had left after four years
went back to work at Mexico Central Bank
and I was sort of lazy about finishing
you know being a natural and how you say
procrastinator can finish my
dissertation one day my senior advisor
calm in Mexico and said you know Ernesto
I'm here in Mexico City I want to invite
you to a meal that to have dinner and
say great let's go and have dinner we
had a nice dinner in the sauna Rosa in
Mexico City and after the dinner he said
Ernesto you haven't finished your
dissertation right you know I haven't
it's a well you know is very simple this
is the end of January 1981 if you don't
show up in New Haven with a full
manuscript of your dissertation by April
30 you will stop being my friend one of
my favorite the students and I will make
sure that you get all over the world
very bad publicity and this in front of
my wife
I was here on April 30 and only because
of that I was able to get a PhD here
well after that I was catapulted into
public service in Mexico you know
interest in positions coordinating with
being president on my country and today
I could ask and answer the question did
my education here made a difference and
not only to achieve those levels of
responsibility that I had but also on
the way in which I conducted myself when
I had those responsibilities and the
answer has to be definitely yes on two
accounts I don't think I would have
never had any opportunity to do what I
was given the opportunity to do without
the education that I received here and
second if I ever took good decisions in
those positions of responsibility every
one of them really had to do with the
way in which I was educated at this
great institution and I say not because
at least in my time the emphasis were on
teaching students about being leaders in
my view I say it with all due respect
and I think now that is very fashionable
I think that's wrong that's crap you
don't come to a place like this to be
taught how to be a leader at least that
that was my experience when I was here
I have tried hard to remember whether I
ever heard the world leader here and I
never heard that but why I do remember
is for example from my courses with
great people like Professor Toby like
professor Dias Alejandro the character I
was talking about before before and
after I came to this place like
Professor gasps Ronnie's still around
like Professor Brainard all of them well
what I what I learned from them was
first and foremost that whoever wanted
to study economics was because that
person should be interested in
addressing human problems of course we
were asked to be rigorous to know
mathematics to know economic theory but
at the end of the day we have to have
the idea that our discipline was first
and foremost to serve people
it was a human discipline addressing
human problems then I also learn several
things the first one was learn to wonder
is to say learn to question learn to be
critic you also learn to learn that was
very important and learn to think was
also important but fundamentally I think
and this was the biggest example I
received from my mentors rather than
learn to be a leader that was implicit
in the message learn to serve and that I
think really marked the way I saw my
professional and my political life and
if only for that I have always been
grateful to this great place then
finally
this is very important if I hadn't
earned a PhD here I wouldn't be here
today
why because actually thanks for having
come here I can get proof rather than
rather than sit down and writing
self-serving memoirs actually for some
of us there is life after the presidency
and what a very life than being a
professor at Yale University